our next topic affects millions of
Americans everyday asthma is the most
common chronic lung condition impacting
children and the CDC has issued a
progress report of sorts analyzing data
from 2001 to 2016 the CDC estimated that
in 2016 one in twelve American children
had asthma in that 15 year time period
those experiencing an attack dropped by
around 8% even more significantly from
2003 to 2013 hospitalizations dropped
roughly by half in half dr. nurullah
this is a tough issue for children how
much education is there targeted towards
children on the subject of asthma
there's really not enough and we've done
better over the last 10 to 15 years but
we have a lot more that we can do when
you look at the fact that one out of six
kids with asthma every year end up in
the ER one out of 20 with asthma end up
hospitalized and many times kids have
more than one exacerbation per year
education can go a long way and when you
look at how we're doing now about 50% of
kids really get the action plan that's
recommended to kind of teach them how to
deal with a situation of exacerbation
about 50% get taught how to use their
peak flow meters less than 50% really
get education on environmental triggers
like air pollution tobacco pet dander
and only 70% get taught how to recognize
those early warning signs or symptoms so
we have a lot more we can do
keeping up with medication is difficult
for adults so I imagine it's got to be
especially tough for kids as a physician
who takes care of adults difficult as a
mom who takes care of kids very
difficult for both adults and kids but
very important and I think if you take
the time as a physician or a parent to
sit down with a child and tell them why
why are we giving you this it can make a
big difference and right now really
about half the kids who should be
getting those control asthma control
medications about half are taking them
regularly as prescribed and 9% are
really overusing the rescue medications
so one other thing I want to mention
before we jump off this is that when you
look at the kids this year hospitalized
with flu the number one comorbid
condition is nazma okay so really
important for kids who have asthma to
get vaccinated for the flu all right
finally eating your greens to preserve
brain health a study published in the
journal Neurology looked at 900
see participants taking part in the
chicago-based memory and Ageing project
they were between the ages of 58 and 99
and completed a food frequency
questionnaire along with two cognitive
tests over a period of nearly five years
major finding eating leafy green
vegetables was associated with slower
cognitive decline in fact those who ate
the most leafy greens showed the
equivalent of being 11 years younger
than their actual brain age kale will
save us all kale spinach collard greens
half a cup of cooked or one cup of raw
it's not a lot per day thing is there's
something yeah and if you're a kid eat
your green that's right and take your
asthma medications they are both good
for your long-term health that works